Hello everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Cutters. Welcome to another episode of Cutters Clinic Live.
I have a very special guest that I met. It's not all that long ago, but she interviewed me
for her summit. This is Dr. Jen Simmons. She is a medical doctor. She graduated from medical school
in Pennsylvania, right? Jefferson. Jefferson Medical School in Pennsylvania. She specializes
in the integrative of functional medicine. Has a lot of course worked on through the Institute
of Functional Medicine. Very active with them and have done just a very, even though you specialize
in breast cancer, really, don't you? Yeah, I did. You've got a lot of specialties in cardio and
hormone and immune and a whole bunch of different things. So let's talk about you. Thank you.
Yeah, so once you train in functional medicine, you kind of learn that you can help everyone,
but my real calling is to the breast cancer community. And it's a very personal story. So when I was
a child, my hero was my first cousin. She was a woman named Linda Creed. She was a singer-songwriter
in the 1970s and 1980s. She wrote all the music for the spinners and the stylistics.
I love it when people know what I'm talking about, but then it also means they're old.
Yeah, I'll take that as a couple of it. I meant it as one, because I also know what I'm talking about.
So for most famous song that she ever wrote was the greatest love of all.
So she wrote that song in 1977 as the title track to the movie The Greatest, starring Muhammad Ali.
Yeah, I love that. But it really, it really received its most acclaim when Whitney Houston re-released it
in March of 1986. And at that time, it would spend 14 weeks at the top of the charts.
But Linda would never know because she died of metastatic breast cancer just one month after Whitney
released the song. Oh, goodness. I was 16 years old at the time. Oh, this is your first cousin,
you said? This is my first cousin. Okay. And I lost my hero. Oh, goodness.
So that made a big impact at 16 years old. A huge impact. I mean, like I was just coming into
being a woman trying to figure out what I was going to do and what contribution that I was going to
make to this earth and my hero, my cousin who was literally a rock star. Like, you know, people use
that term figuratively. My cousin was literally a rock star. And I grew up idolizing her and she was
gone. She was 36 years old and she was gone. And so that her life would have meaning beyond the music
I dedicated my life to helping people to not have to have that reality to not lose their life
and loved ones to breast cancer. So I did the only thing I knew how to do. I became a doctor
and I became a breast cancer surgeon. And I was the first fellowship trained breast cancer surgeon
in Philadelphia. And I really thought that like I had to figure it out. I was making a contribution.
Right. And I think I was. I mean, I really think that I made a huge contribution to that space.
But then in 2016, I got sick myself. And it was at that time that I learned about functional medicine.
To how many years were you a breast surgeon?
I practiced breast surgery for 17 years. Okay. Yeah. And in my 15th year of practice
is when I got sick. It's when I got diagnosed with graves disease. And I was sitting there in the
office and my friend and my colleague and my doctor. And he was telling me that I needed
have surgery. And I needed to take radioactive iodine and have lifelong hormone replacement.
And there was just something that just felt so wrong to me. I was kind of hit by this feeling that
why would God give me an organ only for me to remove it and then have to spend the rest of my life
for placing it. Like it just didn't make any sense. And so I refused treatment. And you know this
was the start of people thinking that I lost my mind. And I went on a quest selfishly to heal myself.
Right. Like my health quest wasn't about making my breast cancer patients lives better because I didn't
know. I didn't know they could be better. I didn't know how much power that they had.
And it was only through learning about functional medicine that I discovered that health doesn't
happen in a doctor's office. And no matter how good a surgeon you are or how good a doctor you are,
that's not where health comes from. Health comes from the patient building their healthy life. And there
are ways that physicians can enhance their health journey. But most of the health journey comes from
the patient. And it comes from doing the things that we know as functional providers build health.
Don't you see in your travels through functional medicine so many practitioners have somewhat similar
stories there. They got sick themselves or a family member got sick and they couldn't help them with
the level of understanding of you know functional physiology that they had. And they had to figure
out something else that it wasn't just you know a pill short some pharmaceutical
missing in that person's life to bring them back to health and they had to start digging themselves.
Yeah, I think everyone comes to this functional space through a very personal story. It's either
their experience or their child's experience or their parents experience. But some some situation
in which traditional medicine really fell short. And that's because you know our traditional medical
system is geared towards symptom management. And it's not geared towards problem resolution.
And that that's very intentional. Unfortunately, it's very intentional because the way that
doctors are paid is by seeing people who are sick. And if they're well and not in the doctor's
office, a doctor can earn a living. And I don't mean to say that physicians want people to be sick
because of course they don't. Of course they don't. They all go into medicine with the best of
intentions. But the problem is that they have to operate, no pun intended, within a system that
only rewards for sick care. And it's very limited. It's what they can do with those sick people too.
So even if you are a physician, let's say you stated your health organization that you were
employed in prior to your revelation of functional medicine, and you were learning functional
medicine, would you be able to practice functional medicine within that system? No, absolutely not.
Because there are standards of care. For instance, if someone comes in with a blood pressure over
a certain number, threshold number, you are obligated to offer them an anti-hypertensive.
You're obligated. That's the standard of care. So you having a conversation with them
about cutting out processed foods, moving their body and sleeping at night is not relevant.
Yeah. Or you looking for heavy metals because this hypertension started acutely, right? So
that's not what we are allowed or entitled to do within the confines of the traditional medical system.
And inside, and the other thing is that the education is provided for
by the pharmaceutical companies, by the device companies, by they are what is gearing education.
And so there's really no opportunity for people to think outside of the traditional model,
because it's really, you know, it's hard to see something that you don't know exists.
Yeah. Right. And so the patients that so many new medical practitioners are basically just
technicians of the pharmaceutical industry. I are. They are. And they are not doing it begrudgingly
or with with any ill intent that they are walking through the system that they have been taught
that they believe them. Yeah. Because we were taught to believe in it and trust it.
Right. And there was no your experience that you thought, okay, well, I got to look at a different
way here. That's when you started go down the functional medicine pathway. How did how did you heal
yourself? Well, it took three years. So I don't want to, you know, make any pretense that it happened
overnight, but it was figuring out what I was doing that was hurting me. That wasn't supporting me
or promoting my health. There were, you know, I, I thought that I knew a lot about nutrition,
because I wasn't overweight. Right. And I think a lot of people suffer under this delusion. And so
because I was able to despite the fact that I come from an overweight family because I was able to
eat in a disordered way that didn't that I didn't gain weight, I thought that I knew about nutrition.
So I had a lot to learn. I had a lot to learn about stress management, how I eat, move, think,
and relate to the world. Well, you changed your whole life through this. You changed your
practice. You walked away from that system. Now you have a practice that that really focuses on
helping with it. Excuse me, women with breast cancer, explain that. Yeah. So when I was a surgeon,
the only person's life that I really implanted was the person that I was working with, right? Because
it's a very one on one thing. And as a surgeon, you don't even really reach beyond that person.
And so I knew once I once I've learned about functional medicine, I knew I wanted to make a bigger
impact. And so what I do is I help people at any point along the breast cancer spectrum, whether you were
worried, you fear about developing breast cancer, you have a brock of mutation, you've been diagnosed
with breast cancer, you're in treatment, you've been through treatment and you're wondering,
now what, or you're living with metastatic disease, I help anyone along that spectrum to reclaim their
health. And my patients enjoy the best health of their lives after their breast cancer diagnosis,
because they finally learned what it means to be healthy.
They finally learned how to, you really work on changing a person's lifestyle, is that right?
I do. I do. And when you do that, you change the lifestyle of their family,
their community, the people that they touch. So it has a tremendous impact. When you teach people how
to be healthy, the ripple effect is tremendous. So you could be preventing a lot of disease that
just cancers in these people's families and further family structures just by touching one person.
So that's the greater impact that you're talking about, right? Yes, yes. And what functional
practitioners know that it's not really well described or understood in the traditional medical model is
that at the root of almost every chronic disease that we know of is inflammation.
Now what causes inflammation in my body might be different than what causes inflammation in your
body and vice versa, but that to be aware of the fact that inflammation is the root cause for most
people, and it is just a question of how you're going to manifest it. So I manifested my inflammation
as autoimmune disease. Now I happen to come from a family that has a spectrum of disease that looks
like autoimmune disease 10 years later, breast cancer or colon cancer. I mean, that's what our family
progression looks like. And other people have different family progressions. Maybe they don't have
the autoimmune stopover. But when you decrease inflammation for people, you stop cancer, you stop
high blood pressure, you stop diabetes, you stop heart disease, you stop any number of these diseases
that we have come to accept as normal results of aging, right? And they're not normal.
It's just that in the traditional medical model, they don't know how to deal with them so they
normalize them. Oh, it's normal to feel badly as you get older. Oh, it's normal to be tired. Everyone
gave their weight as they get older. These are things that are told to us repeatedly
and we bond them, right? We believe them. Well, we're normalizing so many things these days, normalizing
obesity, normalizing ill health in every way. It's supposed to be something we're supposed to accept
as the new normal. You know, there's a lot of talk about prevention. I mean, medicine talks about
prevention. I don't think they know what that word means. They definitely know.
Kind of talk me through that. How you would deal with somebody when you're talking about try to
prevent disease, cancer, sort of, inflammatory process. Because that's the goal, right? So we want to,
we want to get to these people before the disease develops. And so for a lot of people, prevention,
is just around living in anti-inflammatory life. So so many of us are too busy, too scheduled,
not not sleeping, not moving in a way that's productive for our bodies. We are
riddled with stress without tools and coping mechanisms as to how to to deal with that. And we're
eating a diet that is not help promoting. And so you can really move the needle for a lot of people
when you teach them to eat in a way that drives health and move in a way that drives health,
think in a way that drives health, sleep in a way that drives health, avoiding environmental
toxins, and you'll never avoid all of them, but that we can all do a much better job by just
pairing down on what we do and the touch points that we have throughout our day. So there's so much
health that can happen that is in 100% control of the individual. Sorry to hear my dog snoring.
No, I don't. I can't. You think people are afraid of that when they think that they hear about
prevention. Oh gosh, I don't want to do this drastic lifestyle change. Is there a fear in a lot of
people's minds? I think the fear is too bold. First of all, I think that they think that it's too
hard. It's too hard to eat healthy and too hard to commit to that healthy lifestyle.
I think the other thing is that some people are afraid to take ownership of their health.
I was giving a talk on sleep one time to a room full of women with
metastatic breast cancer, and I was explaining to them that there are, you know, thousands of stories
of people who have reversed their disease or living with their disease for three and 40 years,
and this one. I know you have that. This one woman put her hand up and she sent me,
you know, it's just easier for me to blame the medicine for not working than to blame myself.
And I think that resonates with a lot of people. Like they don't want to feel badly about the fact
that, you know, thinking that they caused their cancer, and they don't want to be responsible
for having to reverse it. So, you know, if the drugs don't work, that's the drug failure, not theirs.
Now, you know, of course, I don't think blame or shame helps anyone, right? So thinking that you
caused your breast cancer is not a productive thought, and certainly no one causes their cancer
intentionally. I mean, find me the smoker that lights up the cigarette with the thought that they
are intending to get lung cancer, right? Like no one, no matter what activity you're participating in,
no one intends to get cancer. It just doesn't exist, right? So you have to take that that blame and shame
away and off the table. And then you're, you kind of have to think about like, all right,
well, if you're going to give all your power away to a system that doesn't work, then I think that's
really sad. And I tell people often that that's, that they have to take that power back. It's
easier for an emotional standpoint to put the responsibility on the oncologist when you get
the cancer diagnosis. And then I don't have to worry about it. I don't think about it. It's all
in his hands or her hands and they're going to just fix me. And if they don't, then it's their fault.
That's easier because they don't want, they're afraid of that responsibility. But people have to
take that responsibility. They have to take that because they're given away their power.
Yeah. I agree. Take that back. And then they're giving away their power to something that doesn't work.
Yeah. That's even work. Yeah. So, you know, they kind of get told from the start, like we all know where
this road goes. So I, who wants to come on that journey? Right. I certainly wouldn't want to come on
that journey. And so I think it is the responsibility of people like you and I to shout that there's an
alternative from the rooftops. Now, if people are not up for that and they don't want to take
ownership of their health and they don't want to participate, okay, that's what the traditional medical
model is for. But, but it's hard for me to believe that most people, when really faced with their
mortality, wouldn't say like, all right, I'm going to do it. I'm going to do whatever it takes
to get my health back. Yeah. And so, you know, that's hard for me to understand why people wouldn't do
that either. But you and I both are getting ourselves to think that everybody does because most people
don't, right. Most people don't. Yeah. But that's how, but that's how we decide who we work with and who
we don't, right? Because because I know I can't pull people uphill. Yeah. I can, I can push them from
behind, but I can't pull them uphill. Yeah. Right. And I'm sure that you have the same thing like,
you know, you're not going to waste your time convincing someone to help themselves. Like, they have
to be full on convinced that they can and will help themselves. And then like, absolutely, you'll help
them. Right. Right. I have to be willing to make those those lifestyle changes. Even if they're in
incremental, you know, steps, that's okay. We have to be walking in the right direction.
Yes. Yes. So, you know, if you start in Pennsylvania and you want to go to Florida, no matter how fast you
drive north, you're never getting to Florida. Oh, right. Right. So it's, it's that thing. But you can
drive really slowly and head do self. You'll get there. Yeah. Right. And so it's the same thing like,
you don't have to change everything in a day. Change one thing and let that stick. Then change
something else. We know that these positive behaviors only lead to more positive behaviors.
Like, we know like it gets life. And so I think it's hard to judge from day to day or week to week.
But when you look at these people on day one, and then you look at them again, six months later,
and then again, six months later after that, they're barely recognizable. They're 30 pounds later.
They sleep at night. They have energy out the wazoo. They are happy. They love their life. They are
connected. They're dialed in. These are things that can happen over a year. And life comes with
purpose driven living. And that's what keeps us doing what we're doing right? Absolutely. Yeah.
Absolutely. What's the, what's the most gratifying thing of your practice? What you say?
I just love it when I finish working with someone over the course of a year, and they come to me
and they say, what can I do? Who can I help? Like, I want to pay it. I want to pay it back. And I want to
do what you're doing. I want to come work for you. You know, I know that I have made
a tremendous impact on that person. And then that same person, if they go and become a health coach,
they're going to impact thousands of people. And you know, my goal is to help two million women
through this diagnosis. That's my goal. It's a lofty goal. But I think I can do it. I think I can do it.
You're there yet? I'm not there yet, but I'm going to get there. I'm going to get there.
Well, it's been a pleasure talking to you. I want to have some more conversations. Are you
open to some more conversations on our next podcast? Absolutely. Absolutely. Love to.
I just love your charisma and your energy. And most of all, you're just your
husband to help people. Because that's what's what I hear from patients, the double one thing that's
missing. So they don't feel like they found a doctor that really cares. It cares about them individually.
And that's what's really that's a big key to healing. You know, it is. And you have to do a lot of
listening. I don't have to tell you that. You have to do a lot of listening because most people
who get a cancer diagnosis, that's their body trying to tell them something. There's a message there.
And it often takes us to be quiet, the providers to be quiet, for that message to come through for
people. Yeah. And that's a lesson for the patient to be quiet and be still and know that
God has an answer for them. And sometimes they can only find it in that stillness.
Without question. And I think that your point is well made that that that God understands and has
intentions around what happens with people. And when when people get these big wake up calls,
they need to start to listen and hear what their body is trying to tell them. Yeah. That's exactly
right. Well, that's a good place to end today. And we'll continue on next time. Thank you, Dr.
Jen. We'll have information on this video on where to find you. And to be able to get in touch with
you and find your practice and communicate. It's just what a blessing to have you. Thank you.
Thank you. Bye for now.